successful a historic meeting is taking
place on the Caribbean island of
Barbados
delegates from the African Union Europe
the Americas and the Caribbean are
discussing reparations for the
descendants of victims of the
transatlantic slave trade
barbados's ambassador to the Caribbean
Community or CARICOM says the summit
itself is indicative of the momentum the
international reparations movement has
gained in recent years
we see reparations in terms of the right
to development the way we see
reparations is a look
European countries develop themselves at
the expense of the systematic
underdevelopment of countries like
Barbados and and the Caribbean
territories and the continent of Africa
and reparations is about acknowledging
the criminality that on the lay that and
no taking concrete measures to help
repair some of the damage that was done
just a few miles away from where
diplomats and human rights Advocates are
looking to the Future the history and
Legacy of slavery is more present
this is Newton Plantation one of the
oldest sugar cane plantations on
Barbados it's also the final resting
place for hundreds of enslaved persons
all of this would be a sea of greenery
how many how many enslaved people would
have been working about 200 200
which is quite a lot one Ensley a person
to acre and a half all of it enforced by
the whip by the whip yes and sometimes
the gun historians like Trevor Marshall
say Barbados like other former slave
societies never recovered from the
centuries of Oppression adding that the
road to making things right begins with
reparations over the span of hundreds of
years some half
were enslaved in Barbados now nearly
nearly after emancipation this small
Caribbean nation has become a leading
voice for slavery reparations
the delegates meeting in Barbados this
week are expected to devise an
international framework for advocacy at
an international level building off a
10-point plan for reparatory justice
this includes things like debt
cancellation development projects and
formal apologies from European
governments who activists say continue
to reap the fruits of slave labor
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Bridgetown
Barbados
foreign